you know if you have erectile
dysfunction and you start doing research
on
potential solutions
man you're going to be totally confused
and the biggest strategies for this
condition is all about just managing
this condition but what about fixing it
they don't really talk about that
there's just a lot of data on viagra
different solutions but what we're going
to do is focus more on the problem the
pathophysiology the mechanism of how
this condition could occur
to try to understand the root cause of
this so you can resolve this condition
so many people assume that it's just low
testosterone and they just need to focus
on that but there are people with normal
testosterone that have erectile
dysfunction and there are people with
abnormal testosterone or low
testosterone and don't have erectile
dysfunction so why is that testosterone
is part of the answer but there's
there's more data that i want to share
with you one of the most important
molecules involved in erectile
dysfunction is this thing called nitric
oxide okay nitric oxide n-o our bodies
can make it we can get it from food but
apparently nitric oxide
decreases as you get older it's at a
level of 50
when you reach age 40. and nitric oxide
is a major player in erections in fact
viagra uses
certain nitric oxide pathways and so the
most likely reason for someone with
erectile dysfunction has to do with a
deficiency of this molecule nitric oxide
and what i'm going to be talking about
today is all the things that align with
this theory okay because the more data
you have to back up this theory the more
it's probably true so nitric oxide
is made by your endothelial cells that's
the cells and the inside of the artery
and so nitric oxide it has everything to
do with
helping the arteries
vasodilate
in fact it's involved in something
called endothelium derived relaxing
factor
edrf
so nitric oxide helps relax your
arteries and it increases blood flow not
just with erections but also your
cardiovascular system and other systems
in the body and so if you have low
nitric oxide
you could have asthma for example
so it's intimately involved with the
tone
of the vascular system that relates to
vasoconstriction and vasodilation nitric
oxide increases
oxygen release in your blood and so if
you don't have enough nitric oxide
you're going to have a hard time
breathing the 79 of people with sleep
apnea
have erectile dysfunction
and so that's one connection another
link would be the relationship between
nitric oxide and cortisol it helps to
regulate
cortisol which is a stress hormone and
it's a proven fact that the more anxiety
someone has the more cortisol someone
has the more stress they have the more
they're going to experience erectile
dysfunction in fact someone cannot get
an erection when they're sympathetic
dominant where there's a lot of stress
erections occur when you're more
parasympathetic dominant when you have
low amounts of stress when you're calm
this is why men might get an erection
while they're sleeping because they're
more parasympathetic dominant now here's
another connection that's interesting
nitric oxide
has a profound effect
over testicular steroids this means that
it helps you make testosterone so
there's your connection between nitric
oxide and testosterone if you're low in
nitric oxide you're probably not going
to make as much testosterone nitric
oxide is also involved in luteinizing
hormone that's the hormone produced by
the pituitary gland that controls the
testicles and the amount of testosterone
you're going to make nitric oxide also
is intimately involved in the sleep
cycles including rem sleep this could be
also why if someone has sleeping
problems insomnia or definitely sleep
apnea that they have
a greater risk of erectile dysfunction
nitric oxide also increases insulin
sensitivity
this also explains why a diabetic who
always has insulin resistance usually
also has erectile dysfunction i mean if
you think about it what does high sugar
do to the inside of your arteries it
destroys the endothelial level and
thereby decreasing the amount of nitric
oxide produced people that are on statin
drugs usually have either lower
testosterone or they're at greater risk
for erectile dysfunction and this could
be because statin drugs block
cholesterol which is a precursor for
making testosterone so the big question
now is how do you
increase nitric oxide is there a way to
do it naturally
and the answer is yes number one you can
start doing what's called nasal
breathing start breathing through your
nose
not your mouth apparently when you do
that you increase nitric oxide and you
can also increase the release of oxygen
in your blood by 20 percent by breathing
through your nose because there's more
resistance there's actually 50 percent
more resistance
with breathing through your nose than
your mouth and apparently that increases
nitric oxide to your lungs and the rest
of your body and it also helps you
release oxygen you would think you're
not going to breathe as much but you
actually release more oxygen when you
breathe through your nose
now if you combine that with number two
regular exercise so let's say for
example you're going to do a mild
exercise where you're doing some type of
exercise where you're not breathing
intensively if you can breathe through
your nose you will then increase nitric
oxide and exercise improves
your endothelial cells in your vascular
system which will then improve
nitric oxide now you can also increase
nitrates from foods to improve nitric
oxide okay the foods that are high in
nitrates would be
beets okay
spinach
kale
any of the leafy greens those are all
high in nitrates and will help you
increase
nitric oxide now of course on the flip
side you would want to avoid sugar
because that destroys the inside of the
arteries you would want to avoid alcohol
too because that also decreases nitric
oxide you'd also want to try to keep
your stress low because stress can
inhibit nitric oxide as well and number
five
do things to improve your sleep okay
that's going to help increase your
nitric oxide so these are five natural
things you can do to overcome
the decrease of nitric oxide
which comes from aging now there's
another video if you have not seen this
video
it's about a breathing technique that
relates to
nasal breathing
but it gives you a little more data it's
actually very very important especially
if you want to reduce
cortisol
stress levels and even a panic attack so
check this out i put it right here